a circle with area 81 pi has a sector
with a 350 degree central angle so this
whole sector right over here that's
shaded in this kind of pale orange
yellowish color that has a that has a
350 degree central angle so you see the
central angle it's a very large angle
it's going all the way around
all the way around like that and they
ask us what is the area of the sector
so we just need to realize that the
ratio between the area of the sector
area of
sector
the area the ratio between the area of
the sector
and the total area of the circle and
they tell us what the total area is it's
81 pi
and 81 pi
is going to be equal to the ratio of
its central angle which is 350 degrees
over the total number of degrees in a
circle
over
360.
so the area of the sector over the total
area is equal to the degrees in the
central angle over the total degrees in
a circle and then we just can solve for
area of the sector by multiplying both
sides by 81 pi
81 pi
pi
so these cancel out 350 divided by 360
is 35 over 36 and so our area
our sector area
sector area
is equal to
see in the numerator we have 35 times
instead of 81 i'm just going to write
that as
let's see that's going to be
9 times 9 pi
and the denominator i have 36 well
that's the same thing as 9 times 4
and so we can divide the numerator and
denominator both by 9 and so we are left
with 35 times 9
35 times 9 and neither of these are
divisible by 4 so that's about as
simplified as we can get it so let's
think about what 35 times 9 is
times 9 it's going to be 350 minus 35
which would be 315 i guess
315.
should i do that right yeah it's going
to be 270 plus 45 which is 315
pi over 4.
315 pi over 4 is the area of the sector